Jesus christ said that the poor will
always be among,
you know,
for the first time in human history,
we have the chance to eradicate absolute
poverty.
We have all the resources needed.
It's less,
much less than 1% of the economic output
of the world.
We know how to do it and it is done.
Them and China alone has brought 600
million people of the poverty in the
last few decades.
And we have reduced absolute poverty by
1% every year since 19 1919 but there's
also be a frank reaching the last part
will be more difficult.
They living in franchise states.
Most folks in the,
in the country side,
they are women.
They belong to national minorities to be
a hard task.
But it is possible just about mobilizing
the political will to get the dumb.
So that's a revoke the old slogan.
Yes,
we can.